the next act going into the finals is
[Applause]
after delivering a touching performance
during Tuesday's semi finals the quartet
made up of past and present military
members made it through to the grand
finale
[Applause]
[Music]
to see that kind of reaction from the
crowd how's that feel I've you guys come
down from the high yet oh no oh no no
we're still as high as these heels are
we got floating up there just to get
that kind of love from the crowd and
from the judges and you know we were
already hearing phones are blowing up so
yeah it's it's wonderful with voices of
service moving on sadly it meant
Julianne Hough golden buzzer
twelve-year-old singer Luke Islam was
sent home I think like to have be a 12
year old and sing that and be open and
vulnerable and honest about it and sing
it with such passion and just enthusiasm
behind it it gives other people a voice
that feel that way it feels nothing like
I've ever done before because of the
stages you perform on and all the
rehearsals like it's a lot of work but
it's definitely
[Applause]
swaggy up yeah but like I was doing much
I was really excited I really enjoyed
our performance buzz to come here so our
talents to the world we're just showing
that Detroit is much more than the city
of our joining voices of service and the
DYC
a fan favorite dance group the
unbeatable I never loved when my husband
is right and they were my husband's
golden buzzer all right Joanne way
Junior you were right you guys really
really brought down the house and we did
well how'd it feel up there you guys
have fun Wednesday's Duncan save went to
comedian Ryan nee Miller so that meant
it was up to the judges to choose
between the 2 remaining acts in jeopardy
ten-year-old opera singer Iman beitia
and light artist Alex tOA's I am going
to have to choose a month it's Alex a
man you're gonna be joining that final
[Applause]
[Music]
what would it mean to you to be in the
finale it would be great it would be
like a dream come true